- Hi everyone, this is Sal
Khan here from Khan Academy,
as you might notice, I am
back in the walk-in closet
where Khan Academy first started.
I am socially distanced, like
I'm sure many of you all are.
And I just wanted to
give you a quick message,
because I know in this time of crisis,
there's a lot of anxieties about health,
about the economy, and the
fact that there are a billion
students, and you might be one of them,
who are not in school
who otherwise would be.
And all of us at Khan
Academy, as a not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class
education for anyone anywhere,
we view it as our duty
to step up for the world
during this crisis.
Over the last many years,
we've been building resources
starting in pre-k with Khan Academy Kids
that covers math, reading, writing,
social/emotional learning.
And as you get into elementary school,
with math, and then
we've recently launched
English and Language Arts.
Then we go through middle school
and then in high school, math.
We have things like SAT practice.
That's reading, writing, and mathematics.
And we have sciences.
And we have humanities.
We even go into early college courses.
And we realized that all of those
can help bridge the gap
as we go through this
crisis together globally.
But we wanna do more.
That's why we have been doing things
like webinars and live streams
for parents and teachers
around the world.
We have our daily homeroom live stream
that we're doing for folks.
And we're just trying
to figure out anything
we can do to support you,
the student, the teacher,
the parent better.
I do wanna remind everyone,
we are a not for profit organization.
And that means we are
supported by philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself.
You own Khan Academy as much as I do.
No one is the owner of Khan Academy.
It is a public charity.
And we were already running a deficit
before this crisis hit,
but now our load on our servers is 250%
of what it typically would be,
and it's continuing to accelerate.
And so our costs are going up.
Our budget is the budget
of a large high school,
but we reach a reasonable
chunk of humanity.
And that chunk is getting even larger
and folks need us even more
in this time of crisis.
So, if you find yourself
to be in a position.
You wanna make sure that
other people have access
to free, world class education,
and that students, teachers, parents
around the world are as
supported as possible,
please think about making a donation.